you're all familiar with the millennium
ecosystem assessment this is basically
where the concept of ecosystem services
has come to some kind of popular
knowledge there's an ongoing debate in
ecology and for much longer but this is
where where this concept has come to a
broader setting and now it looks rather
trivial to say okay we have certain
ecosystem services and they directly
provide input to human well-being but I
once listen to a presentation by the
ignore guard who was involved in this
formulation of this framework and he was
telling us about how many workshops it
took them to finally agree between
natural scientists biologists ecologists
on the one hand and then social
scientists on the other to bring these
different points of view and end points
of interest together if you consider
that usually ecology and biology looks
into functions and processes and yeah
social science might be interested in
the fact is nature happening on its own
or is it's constructed by by the
respective Society you you have quite a
bridge a gap to bridge what maybe is is
the most prominent add on to this from
teeb is this although it's not from teeb
as most things are not originally from T
but just pull together by the T village
ative is this differentiating between or
from biophysical structures or processes
that form the the under that are the
underlying fabric of functions to
services to benefits and then finally to
economic value and
this has proven useful heuristic and the
point I want to make with this is you I
think you've been focusing a lot on the
economic value aspect of it I think
often in in communication and if we look
at the examples it it's very very useful
to focus on the service and benefit part
before we look into the value part so
that there's clarity on what are we
talking about and where does this come
from benefit is always to someone so
benefit is something that is that
certain people in society have and if we
have a total economic value that usually
doesn't tell us one bit about who has
these benefits how are they distributed
and and who might and these might also
be this this economic value is a balance
of positives and negatives possibly so
we might have people losing out with
whatever option so besides focusing on
the economic value it's essential
especially if we go into the real world
situations where these trade-offs occur
that we look at benefits and to whom
you